[Music]
from the time I was a
kid the certain characters certain
things that you've seen that have an
impact on you that stay with
[Applause]
[Music]
you and Godzilla was one of
them it's an honor to be
invited by our friends and collaborators
at Toho and at legendary
to play in this monster universe there
is a legacy that goes back 70 years that
we want to be respectful of so we have
to honor everything and maintain
consistency and the thing that was
exciting was to tell a human scaled
story on a monster scaled stage Chambers
deep in the Bedrock there's something
down there oh my God go go go the movies
are so Grand and epic and with a show
like this we get the luxury to explore
it in in episodes which means more
detail more drama it's really exciting
hit the gas
doc there's two timelines happening in
this show one in the ' 50s and one in
the modern era and the present day
characters discovered that they're part
of this interconnected Legacy did our
dad really work for Monarch it is your
family business it's the family curse my
son white and I we're playing the same
person we would go from his period of
time back in the ' 50s to modern day we
had been asked to be in the same movie
usually as Father and Son but the idea
of playing the same person had artistic
element to it that Drew us to it things
I do for Monarch wouldn't have made it
this far without you every time I think
we're searching for D turns out there's
some Monarch business in the way I'm
sorry everything is Tangled Up together
but yes all these roads lead to one
place this crew that we follow in the
present day are just as new to the world
as a new viewer might be welcome to
Monarch sorry they're not scientists and
superheroes they are regular people
everything is new and insane every time
you go to locations in the show it's a
completely different world we shot on a
glacier
move we shot in the desert we went to
Tokyo just
amazing it's the most rewarding
experience to be part of something this
cool this
big I feel like the show we all set out
to do was going to be epic and
adventurous but all of the underlying
feelings are there too this changes
everything the audience who loves the
monsterverse will see a world they
recognize and feel it's been honored and
new fans will watch this and go wow this
is the story that I'm being drawn into
this is a height of entertainment it has
action and excitement and all these
monsters are pretty gnarly I say
that
[Music]